hello and welcome to this rapid game
jar-jar by 11
it's my opponent let's go now to three
don't let it wait for too long for your
board so on the Sun c6 you can actually
transpose to a curl with your for the
funny transposition I will probably no
no the cow can't if you place one c6 so
let's stay within the closed opening
close [ __ ] like right like ready and
so on so yeah two three four the Reggie
gambit
should you for em one of the one of the
good lines for black now he immediately
gives gives me the bishop pair it looks
very much possible yeah and then he six
it might be put Wow Wow okay so how do
we play against this against this
aggression
huh interesting
yeah I'd like to open up the position of
course is the the first instinct that
you have courage em the move h4 he might
have g5 because this is something that
that could work hmm if I go Queen to b3
here he probably just goes Queen to b6
and training Queens is completely
completely completely boring him against
this h5 aggression so H 45 thing really
okay
I wonder h4 takes takes I mean maybe
just d4 93 e4 put it to put everything
into the center after this Wow
so not too easy film to get the Queen
and type into the play Queen b3 now is a
bit more dangerous as Queen b6 is
hanging this but this just this and then
before cannot be bad it doesn't have any
information and then one lips always got
to classical 400 something games that's
really a lot okay so both going back
okay and I go before
mr. frightened what's going I mean
really you're closing this down I know
that g4 was hanging him I mean like yeah
I can I know it wasn't actually hanging
the way you played it and now he takes
on c4 what the heck what the heck in
heck what the what now you're opening it
up or allow me to open it up that is
really strange
so okay d5 why I can take g4 or yeah
everything is good
this is the most normal wolf attacking
on the light squares in the situation
where the light squared bishop SAR
traded and he has moved justice move
pause I mean he just plays with the
spawns you play to bishops moves on the
first couple of loops and then only pawn
moves afterwards okay so on
yeah Bishop g5 is this scent is strong
as Bishop e7 fails due to d6 and then
threatening me five we should be seventy
six wins apiece basically okay so yeah
let's go back
yeah 56 ft six wins apiece it's an
overload Bishop takes Bishop f6 Queen at
six Queen b6 and I win a piece if you
cannot go back because of e5 winning a
piece as well
so I'm winning Abby is here the only
thing going on here is a potential long
careful like 97 and then trying for
castling long and what to do I'm
appealed up for to pawn so I'm not
really worried but I would like to end
this game in the middle game and not
play some some ending
yeah probably this move projects logics
opens up everything and are threatened
d5 so if he castles long u5 is killing
black I don't believe this the long
diagonal it is not canceled
really oke 595 rookie 5 + e5 9525 yeah
let's go in 5
yeah Queen g6 I assume then rook you on
trading Queens
yeah 94 is a good move
it takes on d6 96 with a check and b7 is
hanging
okay so Knight f6 does blunder stuff now
so take and now probably yeah we look
the one where I just quit I just wonder
here 95 maybe that also looks quite good
Jam he's got work T to the org f2 so
cannot cover b7 in anyway so this is a
good move he can cover it with rook b8
but this is not not very critical so
whoopty to look f2 look the a through K
f1
okay so
Roxy wanted to prevent the night for
moving and it's not a youth read this
okay it makes sense though I need to
bring the King out one important thing
is also that term those g4 h three pawns
they they can be picked up in the next
couple of moves probably so going to
place you three know like 94 just go
towards the pawns
it's not so bad to simply take this on
d5 it's not so you're not technically
the easiest thing to do them
I know it is probably relatively easy so
bring the King up now you know the King
on D form together with the knight will
stop any serious pawn advances public
and you can go you can go look at one at
f5 ultimately
okay input Nitin to be for now
completely blocking it
time any place then he plays a
three-night here and then king b5 maybe
just trying to win all the pawns and I'm
not making life difficult for me somehow
and right you right before a three I
have to be a little bit cautious because
this is I never can afford to lose the H
pawn this is something that I absolutely
cannot do ever
let it would be really leading into
trouble
so King and c5i Luke c8 or something
okay I mean a3 is also looking quite
good before 96 bf 198 a and B 2 a check
and go to before it should go a 3 B 4
night a 6p a three-night b8 texts on be
296 check and then the night back I am
stopping all the pawns and sorry III
it helps a little bit
speed things up
you know I can open this up quite
quickly
okay so let's have a look them really
played this I mean use is taking it
pretty mildly probably so um yeah this
six is perfectly okay and then he played
age five okay also go deform G 593 and
maybe Queen b3 but I mean this can never
be bad just to my engine wants me to
take and then play okay with whatever it
does just just never be never careful
like yeah he weakens everything and I
get a big center big central advantage
d5 who came best move especially three
and this is also really rubbish chute
for clique I mean this is opened up and
on what position is that I think this is
just a goodness is just good yeah so
best move was Bishop e7 haha so all this
this and he actually the engine actually
finds a resource here wow I didn't see
this idea of nice I'll just set work
this this and you just go back that
still looks bad now it's better than
Jane I could have just taken on c6 of
course okay now that's nice
and threatening to take everything and
this is the problem he has no time to
take my bishop so that would have killed
him instantly
yeah that's a real mistake there should
be seven
yeah d6 we need the material Queen c7
okay it's very good for what this move
was Knight f6 ah yes that's true that's
true now that that was sloppy
that was really sloppy you know this I
was thinking it takes but of course I
have bishop c6 that thing is coming
right out of the corner and like yeah I
win the Queen I didn't yet okay you
don't look at all that hard if you're a
piss-up I think this was reasonably okay
technically speaking marry five in the
Sun you know night before you know this
is this is not yeah it's so a little bit
of technical work the thing is you have
to be observant that nothing bad happens
here and here on this side of the board
I mean M okay look c1 king c5 it wins
what the engine says but I wanted to
absolutely prevent anything and yet is
prevented I cannot do this
96 is doing this is funny i night it six
wins but for example this actually loses
even though I'm a piece op so this Plus
this he cannot take them young quick
enough yeah blend it into the into the
four cuts okay it's a piece down there's
nothing much there
something that key allotted before and
they have a complete control their ideas
to play at five next and then open or
use the open files on the kingside yeah
thanks for watching guys til next game